[Music]
within each of our characters there's a
certain beauty
within most of them some of them are
just pretty crappy through and through
be like a douchey captain america the
guy who believes
in peace at any cost no matter how many
people he needs to
kill along the way okay i got it
don't ever settle back like you think
you know where this is going because
you don't as soon as you have some sense
about what's about to happen next
james comes in
everyone's exploding genitals heads arms
legs
it's like a big massive graphic novel
brought to life this is by far the
biggest movie i've ever
made i don't think that you know what to
expect
don't get too attached this has been
truly
the greatest most exciting
journey of my life making this film
cut that was great
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the new
suicide squad teaser and hbo
announcement
if you don't know what's going on
there's going to be a new suicide squad
big budget tv show on hbo
in 2022. there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs i'll explain
what they're doing with it which
characters are going to appear in it
it's just like the batman
spin-off tv show that matt reeves is
doing from the batman movie with robert
pattinson
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of
course i'll be doing episode videos for
this when it does premiere there's a
bunch of big hbo dc series that they're
working on right now that we're gonna
see in the next couple of years
so just starting with the big stuff
first number five warner brothers
obviously just announced that there's a
suicide squad tv show for hbo max coming
in 2022
it will star john cena's peacemaker
character from the suicide squad movie
that's dropping next year
in a bunch of other characters from that
movie now i know the first thing most of
you said
in my timeline when i was tweeting about
this the other day was how are we going
to watch it if we can't see
john cena so i'm sure that's going to be
the top comment on every single suicide
squad episode video that i do when the
show eventually premieres
post all your john cena memes it's going
to be crazy
the way james gunn explained the show is
that he said he had so much extra time
to kill
between the filming of the suicide squad
movie and guardians of the galaxy 3 over
in the marvel cinematic universe that he
spent all that extra time this past year
in lockdown just writing a suicide squad
tv show
he said that it started when warner
brothers came to him looking for more
big budget dc
justice league tv shows for hbo max in
peru's comments they basically asked him
if he could have any characters from the
movies the dc movies
to base a tv show around who would those
be and john cena's peacemaker was one of
the characters that he picked the series
is going to be eight episodes long
obviously it'll run for multiple seasons
we already know a lot about his
character and what the tv show is going
to be like
compared to the movie but this should be
no surprise it's just a continuation of
warner brothers spending
huge money for more movie crossovers
with the dc movies on hbo max
they just announced matt reeves was
doing the batman tv show for hbo max a
little while ago
that's going to be a batman spin-off set
during batman year one
inside the new university's creating for
robert pattinson's batman movie
the batman movie itself is gonna take
place during batman year two still very
early proto-era batman
compared to other batman movies like
christian bale's batman begins
but number four a lot of you will
remember this isn't the first time that
warner brothers has tried to do
a suicide squad tv show a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away
you may remember they tried to do a
version of the suicide squad on arrow
before the first suicide squad movie was
released if you ever had any hope of joe
manginello's deathstroke coming back in
the dc eu
it would be on this suicide squad tv
show or any suicide squad movie sequels
that james gunn winds up doing
and if you're still salty about that all
those people at warner brothers have
since been fired so
if you're still upset about what
happened with zack snyder in the justice
league snyder cut
the first suicide squad movie debacle
all those people have famously or
infamously been fired now that they've
launched hbo max they need to convince
people that it's worth paying the money
to subscribe and they need to compete
with avengers marvel disney plus shows
in the stuff that netflix is putting out
so it's a no-brainer that they're
reaching into the toy box for big budget
dc
content from the dceu they're also doing
the green lantern core series they're
doing a full-blown
justice league dark team-up series
they're doing a new constantine series
in zatanna all those are happening on
hbo
and that's only just a small part of it
they're doing way more stuff that they
haven't announced
yet i know everyone wants to hear the
news that ben affleck is coming back to
do a batman hbo series
but that's not actually happening matt
reeves batman hbo series is the only
batman series that they're working on
right now
number three but what is this suicide
squad hbo series actually going to be
about
well the plot synopsis that james gunn
in the studio released says that it will
explore the origins and adventures of
john cena's peacemaker character
and during the suicide squad trailer as
they say he's the douchey version of
captain america from marvel's avengers
the reason why he was locked up and
forced to become a member of the suicide
squad is because he kills
so many people he's almost closer to
being like dc's version of the punisher
he believes in peace at any cost
so much that he's willing to kill as
many people as possible to make it
happen
that's where his name peacemaker comes
from the version of the character that
john cena is playing is the christopher
smith peacemaker who debuted back in
1966 in charlton comics title called
fightin five charlton comics is also
where blue beetle and captain adam came
from
dc bought them early on and gained the
rights to all those characters
his version of peacemaker had a
short-lived run with the suicide squad
in the comics and seemingly
died when lasting crashing a helicopter
into eclipso
in a bid to kill him they're actually
doing eclipso on star girl season 2 but
that's a cw show so that's not connected
to what's going on with suicide squad
hbo
stuff if you read that big dc watchman
crossover watchmen doomsday clock that
was a big dr manhattan vs superman title
peacemaker showed up in the background
of that too
so obviously there's not a ton of
pre-existing story for his character in
the comics like there is for people like
batman superman wonder woman the holy
trinity
because the new batman hbo show is going
to be a prequel to the batman movie with
robert pattinson
when james gunn was asked that same
question is this going to be a prequel
suicide squad show to the new movie
he said that they were waiting till
after the movie was released to announce
what the timeline of the show is going
to be
mostly just to prevent spoilers as to
whether or not john cena's character
gets killed off during the movie
because the whole tagline that they're
going with to promote it is don't get
too
attached as in most of those characters
will probably get killed off during the
movie that's the whole idea they're
expendable
it would be weird if they didn't kill
them off but he did say that just
because the show is exploring the
origins of john cena's character it
doesn't confirm
that it's a prequel so my assumption
just based on what he's saying is that
he's going to survive the suicide squad
movie and the show will mostly take
place in the future
after the events of the movie and
they'll just do flashbacks to his
origins in early years
taking the mantle number two i know
you're all asking how is this connected
to the justice league movies the dc eu
movies
since it's them doing the exact same
thing as one division
falcon and winter soldier over in the
marvel cinematic universe with those
avengers characters
showing up in their own tv shows the
suicide squad show obviously is totally
connected to all the dceu movies
i know it's kind of a weird case with
robert pattinson's batman movie because
that's kind of in a self-contained
bubble of continuity by itself it's not
really connected to justice league
right now maybe after the flash movie
and flashpoint that'll be a different
but the new suicide squad movie itself
is not a complete reboot it will
acknowledge the first movie and some of
the characters from that first movie are
coming back like rick flagg
captain boomerang amanda waller they all
show up during that trailer
they haven't said exactly what the
timeline is going to be other than
it's after the events of the justice
league movie because
one of the clues that they gave us is
that idris elba's character bloodsport
is in prison for shooting henry cavill's
superman with a kryptonite bullet so
obviously it has to be after he comes
back to life during the justice league
movie
and even though the story of the justice
league snyder cut for superman is going
to be
vastly different than the theatrical cut
the movie still takes place in the same
point in the timeline that part isn't
changing
in number one i know a lot of you were
asking about the rumors of henry cavill
signing a new superman contract recently
but warner brothers hasn't made any
official statements and henry cavill
himself
recently in interviews has said that a
lot of what he's heard people
saying on the internet isn't totally
true and he did say he's not planning on
correcting anyone's statements he's just
gonna stay
quiet about it until the studio wants to
make their own announcement themselves
but yeah i think we all agree he's
totally coming back in some cameos
the rock even spent all of that black
adam trailer
at dc fandom hyping up black adam versus
superman and then black adam versus the
entire
justice league but let me know in the
comments what are you most hyped up for
in this new suicide squad hbo series
and which other big dc hbo series do you
want them to do in the future
because it sounds like they are shopping
for a ton of justice league spin-off
series
while you wait for everything click here
to re-watch that new batman trailer a
billion more times and click here for
that brand new avengers wand division
trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you